we got some really good news TBS just a
few days ago announced that they picked
up our show for four more years it goes
to it takes us to like 2022 and this
show started in 93 that's almost that's
29 years almost 30 that's crazy 20 22
doesn't sound like a real year right
yeah at this point to me it sounds like
a sci-fi movie yeah yeah well anyway the
cuts of the chase this was a huge
extension we couldn't be happier
everyone here is very excited you've got
that right okay that's uh that's Tony
he's one of our cameramen Tony what are
you doing there
oh I'm shopping for yachts you're
shopping for yachts yeah yeah since the
show's been picked up for four more
years I figured this was the perfect
time to start building my fleet okay
Tony I'm sorry that's a bad idea yachts
are incredibly expensive oh yeah yeah
the ones I bought were very pricey let
me understand this Tony you've already
bought more than one yacht yeah that's
right I bought one yacht for each year
the show's been extended so that's four
yachts and now to celebrate my purchase
of those four yachts I'm shopping for
yacht number five it's got to be the
kind of yacht that says congrats on your
first four yacht okay let's say look
Tony this is incredibly irresponsible
it's very irresponsible yeah Tony and
yachts aren't just expensive there they
cost a lot to maintain yeah you got to
pay for fuel dock space maintenance Tony
what are you doing
first name Tony last name the cameraman
all one word yeah I'm very I'm very
excited to be a member okay goodbye the
yacht of the Month Club so I didn't hear
you guys I was busy joining the yacht of
the month
yeah I just heard the yacht of the Month
Club that's insane all right come on
relax it's only for 72 months Tony I
don't know a lot but I'm pretty sure you
can't afford one yacht much less 72
yachts 77 don't forget the first five
Hey all right all right all right Tony
you've got to stop shopping for yachts
I've got to stop shopping for yachts
you've you got to stop shopping for
yachts
okay I'm sorry that's one of our other
caromed Ravi
what's so funny Robby it's just that
every time you guys say shopping for
yachts it sounds like you're cursing in
Italian I have no idea what you're
talking about
well you just you know and shopping for
yachts good one Robby
shopping for yachts
[Applause]
shut up seriously both of you now Tony
you've gotta unload all those yachts or
you're facing financial ruin whoa well
when you put it that way I guess I have
no choice
rolling I bought too many yachts I can't
afford them all so now I'm selling them
at deep discounts 20 30 even $50 off
like this 2016 win bond at 5,000 I've
paid six hundred forty thousand dollars
for it you pay just six hundred thirty
nine thousand
or this 2014 islandhoppper 2s series I
paid $125,000 you also pay that five
yachts get the six got for $100 off okay
dizzy I already named them for you I'm
to yacht to handle I'm like a Cat on a
Hot Tin Roof other puns like my old
Italian Graham I used to say shopping
for yachts
curious hey Tony did it work did the ad
work yup I sold all the yachts okay
Tony is that a private jet catalog oh
why sure is oh oh shopping for jets
about both
shopping for jets
you